[music]
>> This is again the dictionary of Islam by
Thomas Patrick.
Use.
It's a dictionary of Islam.
These were just a few encyclopedias. Now
lately there are
some that have come
in the market.
Here again the footnote mentions
unfortunately there are no comprehensive
encyclopedias on Islam which have been
completely written and edited by
Muslims. Thus we have to refer to the
above mentioned encyclopedias even
though many a time Islam has been
misrepresented. There's a footnote
there.
This is again mentioned 20 years back.
Now as I mentioned there are
more that have come but yet not as
voluminous as what has been done by
these people.
There's a section called as Arabic
English dictionary.
As that will be Arabic and English.
Arabic is a very important language.
Or rather the important language? And
it is
very important that a day should know
Arabic as a language. I don't know
Arabic as a language, little bit here.
Sure, sure, fine. I can manage my way
through.
Little bit, but not as a language.
Therefore, in our school which we'll
discuss
on that day,
masha'Allah,
all our students from the Islamic
International School, they learn Arabic
from the age of three.
Alhamdulillah. By the time they reach
standard five, six, they can understand
Quran to a great extent. By then they
reach standard nine, 10, they can even
translate portions of it, alhamdulillah.
The Lanes is one of the very famous
Lanes Lexicon. Again,
it is not by a Muslim, but as a good
reference source in eight volumes that
goes to the root word and where does the
word come from and the root word consist
of three alphabets in Arabic and you put
the Arab and how it got derived, etc.
This is a dictionary from Arabic to
English.
Why I keep this? Because Arabic we don't
have that much of mastery. So, when
someone tries to pull a fast one, we
have something with us where we can
defend ourselves.
If you disagree with the person,
sometimes we get into argument. So, this
is a good reference for knowing Arabic.
Arabic to English.
It's a lexicon.
There's Lisan al-Arabia.
This is by Hans Wehr,
a dictionary of modern written Arabic.
The last section,
we're running short of time,
is the Concordance and Index of the
Glorious Quran.
The Concordance and the Index of the
Glorious Quran. Number one is
al-Mu'jam al-Mufahras.
This has been very helpful for me.
When you want to know,
but now you have other means.
Now you have computers, it's easier, but
at that time when it wasn't so advanced,
20 years back, this was a good tool for
me.
Mu'jam al-Mufahras. What does it do if
you want to know how many times this
word occurs in the Quran?
Then you go there, you read the Arabic,
it tells you all the references of the
Quran.
How many times the word Muslim is
referred? You get the ad there. How many
times Nisa is mentioned? You get the
word there. How many times Kalb is
mentioned? You get the reference there.
It's in one volume. It's only Arabic.
So, if you know Arabic, it's good. If
you can read also, you can manage.
That's a very good reference where you
can go and you can see how many times
this particular word has come. Today,
there are softwares available,
but yet this has its own value as a
book. Print media has a different value,
a software has a different value. Each
has their pros and cons. We'll discuss
it later on, inshallah.
But you want to know how many times this
has occurred in the Quran and you want
to find particular words of the Quran,
it's helpful in finding verses
by using this
type of Mu'jam.
Then you have concordances.
Uh this is a
concordance and index of the Holy Quran.
Same. Muhammad Fu'ad Abdul
Baqi.
It's completely Arabic.
Mu'jam al-Mufahras. The index come
concordance of the Holy Quran.
This is by Al Hajj Khan Bahadur.
These are concordances in English
available. I have not used them much. It
is there in English language. I prefer
going to the that original that has
better references in the Mu'jam.
This is the concept of the Holy Quran
topic leading by Fateh Usman.
There is easy dictionary of the Quran
by Sheikh Abdul Karim Parekh.
Dictionary of the Quran.
And there are many books again in this
category.
There are the books apart from Quran,
Hadith, then dictionaries, concordances
in Arabic.
I've just mentioned a few books, just
the basics.
This is the Kitab al-Tawhid
by Sheikh al-Islam
Muhammad ibn Abd al-Wahhab,
rahimahullah.
Again, a very important book.
Has been criticized by many Muslims
because of its authenticity, but it's a
very good book
on tawhid, and one of the most important
books, Kitab al-Tawhid. In the series we
had on Kitab al-Tawhid on Peace TV by
Sheikh Salim al-Amri,
tawhid is the most important factor in
religion. So, this is the book on Kitab
al-Tawhid.
This is Taqwiyat al-Iman, Strengthening
of the Faith, by Shah Ismail Shaheed.
Then there's a book
called The Major Sins.
That's Al-Kabair,
the major sins, and very important for a
person to know what are the major sins.
This is the book on
the major sins
by Muhammad al-Dhahabi.
The Stories of the Prophets, again by
Ibn Kathir.
This is The Stories of the Prophets.
If you want to know the stories
mentioned in the Quran
of the prophets, beside Muhammad
Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam,
it's given here. If you want to know all
the stories mentioned in the Quran of
the prophets, this is a very good book,
definitely book. We also have a series
for the children on The Stories of the
Prophets.
Now, coming to the book of
the Khulafa al-Rashidun. There are many
books on the companions of the prophet.
One of the most important and one of the
best written books on the biography of
the Khulafa al-Rashidun
is
by Sheikh Dr. Ali Muhammad al-Sallabi,
and he has written on all the four
Khulafa al-Rashidun.
This is the book, biography on Hazrat
Abu Bakr,
may Allah be pleased with him.
This is Hazrat Uthman, may Allah be
pleased with them both.
And this is Hazrat Ali,
may Allah be pleased with him. This book
by Sallabi
is one of the good books in which, as I
said when you write a biography many a
time people use historical facts and
even quote Hadith. He has taken care
that I cannot say 100% is sahih but
almost all majority of the Hadith and
the references taken are from the
authentic sources.
It's not only authentic Hadith but
historical facts also there in it. But
he has tried to see that most of it is
authentic. There are various biographies
of the Khulafa Rashidun. The one written
by Sallabi is one of the most popular
and one of the most authentic available
in the market. And if you want to read
about the life history of the four
Khulafa Rashidun, Hazrat Abu Bakr,
Hazrat Umar, Hazrat Usman and Hazrat
Ali, may Allah be pleased with them all.
Inshallah, this book is a good
reference. This was in short talking
about
few sources
few books.
It's a drop in the drop.
It's a drop in the ocean, a drop in the
drop
only. Our library is also very small
having only about 20,000 books, very
small library. We just got
some of it here. It's an ocean.
One thing to be noted, the more
knowledge you get, the more you know
you realize
the less you know.
It's a very important thing. The more
you know
you realize
the less you know.
And as age is crossing
I
know nothing we know.
Initially when I died I think it's all
Quran khalas. I know whole Islam.
When you read the Quran, oh there are so
many tafasir.
OKAY, THEN YOU THERE'S ALSO HADITH.
HADITH, OKAY. I know Hadith. Oh, Hadith.
Sahih, za'if, this, that. Then the more
you know, you realize the less you know.
Believe me, there's so much to learn.
As time passes you come to know that you
have wasted your life.
Knowledge is something which never ends.
And when we meet the scholars,
we really feel that what they have
achieved,
we have not even scratched the surface.
We are far behind. And I crave that may
Allah give us the time, the energy, the
strength to acquire and implement this.
Acquiring is one thing, implementing is
something. May Allah accept our efforts.
We have not even scratched
maybe the dust on the surface. Leave
aside the surface.
We haven't scratched the dust
of the surface. Therefore, I'm telling
you this session, this training program
is not about knowledge.
Others may claim this is
knowledge-based, that-based, that-based,
etc.
We didn't have the time for
introduction, otherwise I've told you
what is the difference in our training
program compared to others.
That's the reason
something you can gain. Masha Allah,
many of you
are young.
Or younger than me, even I'm younger
than I say.
You have yet a lot to gain. Some are 19
years, some are 20, 22,
30. Masha Allah, the eldest is Masha
Allah, brother Kamruddin.
Masha Allah, giving competition to me.
Masha Allah.
In age, 47.
47, no?
47 3/4. I'm 50 and a quarter. So, you
have the time now. Therefore, I tell my
son, gain knowledge. This is the age.
We think where have we wasted our
time in learning medicine.
If we had learned at least a small
portion of this, it would have benefited
us much more.
But again, Allah's help is there,
Allah's mercy is there, Allah's kindness
is there. Otherwise, we are nothing.
Hadha min fadli Rabbi. All this is only
due to the mercy of Allah Subhana Wa
Ta'ala.
So, now you all have the time,
make
the most use of it.
Knowledge
is power.
I start my talk by saying "Rabbi zidni
ilma."
That oh my Lord, increase me
in knowledge.
From Surah Taha.
Who knows the reference?
Surah Taha?
14.
Good, mashallah.
This was part of the homework, correct?
Oh my Lord, increase me in knowledge.
We pray to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
that may he
give us more knowledge so that we can
spread his deen.
And may he make us utilize to the best
of ability.
Inshallah, we'll have a short break
of half an hour for tea.
We'll resume by
11:30. Maybe 25 minutes late.
11:30 so that we are
less behind, inshallah. So, 11:30 we'll
be back in this auditorium. Inshallah,
we break.
Wa akhiru da'wana anil hamdu lillahi
rabbil alamin.
La ilaha illallah.
La
ilaha illallah.
Muhammadun [music]
rasulullah.
Arju ridhaka ya Allah. Anta rahimu ya
>> Allah. Habni ataka ya
>> Allah. Antal karimu
minkal atao ya
>> Allah. Antal azimu ya Allah. Fikal rajao
ya
>> Allah. Antal halimu
Rahmanu sattaru malikul mulkil ghaffaru
wahhabul mannanul muta'ali.
a man